تذهب تقارير غربيه الى ان الذهب يلعب دورا
في الصراع على السلطه في السودان حيث يشكل
مصدر ماليا مهما لقوات الدعم السريع فضلا
عن كونه محطه انظار اقليميه ودوليه ويعزز
التدخل في الشان السوداني فالسودان تمتد
على خارطته مناطق غنيه بمختلف الثروات
المعدنيه وفي مقدمتها المعدن الاصفر
وحاليا يحتل السودان المركز الثالث عشر
عالميا بين البلدان المنتجه للذهب
وافريقيا هو ثالث اكبر منتجي القاره بعد
غانا وجنوب افريقيا وتصل تقديرات ما ينتجه
السودان من الذهب الى نحو 80 طنا ويسهم ما
يعرف بالتعدين التقليدي او الاهليه في
السودان ب 80% من الذهب المستخلص وتقدر
الاحتياطيات الاستراتيجيه غير المستغله
بنحو
1550 طنا
ومنذ انفصال الجنوب تعتمد الخرطوم على
الذهب كمصدر اساسي لتوفير العملات
الاجنبيه اذ يمثل نصف صادرات البلاد وقد
بلغت عائداته تصديره في النصف الاول من
العام الماضي نحو مليار وثلاثمائه مليون
دولار ومع تردد ظروف السياسيه والاقتصاديه
ازدادت وتيره عمليات تهريب الذهب حيث وصلت
نسبتها في بعض الاحيان الى 80% من الانتاج
وفقا بتقديرات رسميه توجد بالسودان شركات
تابعه للحكومه وشركات تابعه للجيش ولكن
ابرزها واكبرها تلك الشركات التابعه لقوات
الدعم السريع هذا اضافه الى شركات من دول
اخرى مثل الصين وكندا وفرنسا واستراليا
وروسيا ويقدر عدد الشركات الدوليه بنحو
140 شركه وتنشر في مناطق التنقيب عن الذهب
صراعات عنيفه من حين لاخر وربما هذا ما
دفع صحيفه في
الى القول ان مجموعه الظنر الروسيه ترتبط
بعلاقات مع حميتي حيث تعمل شركه ام ان
تتبعت لفاجنر في مجال تعدين الذهب
بالسودان وحسب تقارير غربيه تقع نسبه
كبيره من نشاط تعديل وتجاره الذهب وتصديره
تحت سيطره قائد قوات الدعم السريع محمد
حمدان المعروف بحميتي والذي يسيطر هو
وعائلته منذ عام 2017 على عده مناجم
باقليم دارفور وتبلورت تلك السيطره في شكل
شركه الجنيد التي يتراس مجلس ادارتها
شقيقه عبد الرحمن ديلو القائد الثاني
للقوات الدعم السريع لكن ومع المطالبات
بوضع جميع الثروات السودان الطبيعيه تحت
سيطره الدوله اشترط الدجلو اواخر عام 2020
للتنازل عن شركه الجنيد لوزاره الماليه
الحصول على 34% من شركه سودامين الحكوميه
للتعدين والتي تديرها وزاره الماليه
بالاشتراك مع البنك المركزي
ووفقا لوكاله الانباء السودانيه تعد دوله
الامارات ابرز المستفيدين من ذهب السودان
اذ تشتري اكثر من 90% من انتاجه قد لا
يكون ذهب هو المعدن الوحيد الذي يسخر به
باطن الارض لكنه ليس بعيدا عن خلفيات
الصراع فوق الارض في السودان